oh my gosh we're not worthy we're not
worthy what's up y'all it is almost the
Grammy's time and we have all the things
music here at the Kelly clarkon show so
today I thought I'd bring in two of my
fellow band mates joaco and Lester
[Applause]
is Johnny Cash yes you picked the two
buffest dudes on the stage now this is
true been
this is my trainer right here this's
been training I know and it's also my
roommate wait were you all I know at
them romance so today I am challenging
you to um to a game of a song title
Emoji song title Emoji I can't say it
but I can win the game okay okay it's
the Grammy Edition are you ready oh yeah
I know every song all right I played
this against Jesse last year and well I
won have you ever lost um I've never
technically lost this game technically
sounds like cheating no technically
because one time we sort of tied Jesse
and I I say sort of cuz but
anyway so these are all either Grammy
nominated songs albums or artists this
year I'm not feeling confident I'm going
to be honest with you I was all talk
just them I'm not feeling confident this
is what no she's like I don't know I
don't know anything she's like bam blah
blah blah bam blah blah blah every time
are you ready to get beat let's let's be
the sharks see we can do this okay okay
let's play here we
go
[Music]
antihero Taylor Swift oh that's good Joo
like not in a billion years was I going
to get that I got a new confidence wow
okay got
it uh vampire uh Olivia
Rodrigo oh my God woo I must be butter
cuz I'm on a roll my God I don't like
this at all beating us
and then slapping us
jokes love it and we're the ones with
kids's ridiculous fine it's fine I
didn't have a clue on either okay yeah
you Sayang it
yeah nail nail nail house Apple
neighborhood though that's that's nail
nails house Nails
house Apple fruit apple it's red so
that's Nails house red nails house red
nails apartment Red Nails Nails condo
red nails what paint paint paint the
town red paint the town red DOA cat oh
my God that was good I have no idea what
that song is now yeah you do it's the
one she sampled de welcome back yeah I
was like it's played everywhere
wow well I thanks for all the help nice
job
no wonder Kelly's won every single one
and like this and this and this no when
nobody's King he starts giving us new
Clues okay album ooh infinity sun
infinity sun Beach oh oh um she's uh
she's in mine myos Cirus Endless Summer
Endless Summer
[Laughter]
[Music]
Vacation close enough okay Frozen pepper
Frozen cold pepper spice
yeah I was thinking songs not artist I
know I forgot I forgot I forgot too yeah
yeah we should redo that one Frozen
pepper no don't take away my point dance
Moon Star Dance Moon Star Dancing On The
Moon Like a Star Dance Star moonshine
dancing dancing on the moon dance dance
we need some we need some clothes oh yes
I think I know what it is but I can't
remember the song name this literally
giving you the hints though it's um it's
she she moon no it's like dance the
night star or something like that it's
dual Lipa no Dua dance the night star no
dance the night away dance the night
dance the night I have no guesses I feel
like I get that I'm going to give that a
point yeah this is so bread bread tracks
bread rails track bread train bread
Trail food train bread um oh it's an
album oh album okay carb car car car
rail bread french bread
French French it's one ra it's one
word oh it says album I didn't I just
noticed that it says that at the top
like a bakery baking tracks Subway Trail
subway train I have no idea Sub sub
that's pretty good though sub track
that's good work oh oh okay I was like
no no oh okay I got it my hair
my she beat meang it did you like the
feel of the top is
my I almost got cut with all that bling
flowers needle running and needle
running blow needle run blow needle yarn
run blow jog blow needle artist Running
With The Wind no so needle oh it's an
artist it's an
artist um so what are artists that we
think are a needle yeah needle needle
who jop is it to do that seamstress SE
seam stress running blow I'm going to
that
[Music]
one that's tlor Swift oh a Tor actually
pretty clever pry CL very clever with
the person running okay very that is
that is but why did you have her farting
she's swi she's winning yeah she's yeah
that's
wi wa
[Music]
chemistry yes you deserve to get you
deserve get I never get
mine nomed this year oh yeah thank you
thank you ghost G down down ghost down
what is that gear setting oh uh ghost
ghost in the
machine good job I'm going is somebody
keeping track am I winning you should be
it's don't start with me don't don't
that was a public shame it was yeah she
like
hesitated
butterfly huh I didn't say
that he said butterfly I don't get that
one I don't get that one I literally
said I said butterfly and then and I was
like flight and I accidentally said
flight I got a bit too foret I did mean
butterfly but I didn't say it I said
butterfly so that doesn't count that
means we're still four to four to one
question question I ham Hammer luck
Hammer luck question I hammer luck it's
a for it's a song qu um why why I why do
I hammer why do I why do I pound why do
I pound Clover four four they keep
saying four why do I oh what was I made
for Billy
ish
D that's good help me I didn't he
something he said clicked yeah good song
Good song
yeah my gosh don't let her win all you
got this aish book go book lights street
lights
green Olivia
Rodrigo oh my gosh oh my goodness how
did I get that was I was like one GRE
we're not worthy we're not
worthy oh my gosh the ear got me off at
first but I saw the Rodrigo oh I love
I'm glad I got go wow that was good well
thanks for joining me I won again but
oh I hate this how many wait I got six
how many four one why y
atast
l right no that was we got to have a
rematch we got to have a rematch okay
okay the Grammys are on Sunday February
4th good luck to everyone nominated let
us know in the comments your favorite
songs and artists nominated this year go
ahead and throw my name out there H just
kidding we have another show to film
that's right oh yeah let's work what are
we oh yeah I'm seeing some horing all
right here we go let's go
everybody guys oh my God that last one
was
[Music]
[Applause]
amazing thank you guys yall have a great
night I'm going
home